[Music]
um
look at this guy you've been in the
weight room you're a big [ __ ] i can see
it
are you gonna wear something outrageous
tomorrow and make us look weird uh
probably
i was there i was there dude i was there
okay are you performing this weekend
uh i think i might do a pop-up set
tonight damn yeah justin timberlake you
got five stars
[ __ ] that guy i know [ __ ] that guy all
right guys love you
thank you brendan we'll talk to you soon
you know what i'm saying yeah [ __ ] there
was actually
nothing like so you gotta bring
entertainment we need guys like you and
you'll be
so daddy all right what's up look if you
guys come to mind at me and not dress
like this
it's the only time you get away with a
man can't have two dirty white sneakers
where is he sitting you know yeah
welcome to this very special episode of
food truck diaries we call it poolside
diaries
because i your boys in miami that's why
i'm dressed like a thick ass don johnson
and i couldn't look more colombian cool
story dude
god the man of the town i think well you
i think it's fair to say the man
i mean your brother's fighting this
weekend but there seems to be
the buzz is all jake paul at least in my
world too even to me like you that's
only your third fight
you only have to do three [ __ ] fights
yeah and so everyone
and to be to even to be the guy like ben
and seen it
but i don't really necessarily care
about people taking me seriously as a
boxer
i appreciate
see i'm trying to bring people back to
la we're opening it up
bringing him back to l.a where do you
move [ __ ] puerto rico how are you
doing brother follow your association
man good to see you again i'm blessed
man i'm good can't complain
thank you yeah i'm coming along you know
yeah
seeing you in miami sir it's a pleasure
to be here i know i love you man
you know you always got food too that's
how i roll it's one thing
that's where the nickname big boy comes
from dude i'm fighting this guy
done yeah you don't care about the
rankings at that point correct because
if so many millions of people want to
see that go down it's gonna happen it's
cracking well it's kind of
when i was watching the first week i
watched the video the first two
by the airport she was like
that's a wrap huh i think don johnson ow
can i look any more latin right now
what's up daddy what's up puppy
just wrapped up poolside diaries with
jake paul
t wood i had a little bit of down time
by a little bit i mean 45 minutes
changed the fit still looking like razor
ramon
had the miami improv doing a drop-in set
on mrs pat's
shows so let's see how it goes let's
ride what's up brother
hello
appreciate it i don't know if you guys
ever officially met miss paddy's
[Music]
[Applause]
my word so we started off with what we
had uh morning combat did that show
did the pool side diaries with freaking
jake paul
t wood my boys and then little down time
switched up the outfit
apparently transformed into razor ramon
so that's cool
uh just got off stage at the miami
improv miss pat was kind enough to let
me do a hot 10 minutes for
uh i love miss patch she's a monster
haven't seen her check her out
have dinner with the showtime boys and
that's day one
is